ce qui devait être une grande
célébration d'Halloween et rapidement
devenue un cauchemar des milliers de
jeunes réunis pour fait soigner
deviennent prisonniers des petites ruses
étroites du quartier
iteo en acier hall
des scènes de chaos dans la panique
disant tentent de fuir par tous les
moyens
[Applaudissements]
alors que la fête se poursuit dans le
quartier au sol des centaines de corps
inanimés certains déjà recouverts par
des couvertures
des équipes d'urgence sont à pied
d'oeuvre pour aider les blessés des
hôtels réquisitionnés sont transformés
en hôpitaux de fortune un poste de
commandement est dirigé
les pompiers ont demandé de l'aide j'y
suis allé pour aider à la réanimation
raconte ce témoin qui était lui aussi
pris dans la foule
je n'aurais jamais pensé que ce genre de
situation puisse arriver en Corée
surtout a été one raconte le barman
c'était le premier rassemblement
d'importance depuis le début de la
pandémie de covid-19 en Corée du Sud on
ne connaît ni l'ampleur du drame ni la
cause des médias locaux rapportent que
la présence d'une célébrité dans une
boîte de nuit aurait déclenché cette
bousculade meurtrière
ici qui me permettra au Canada Montréal